是遇到了一些感情上面的事情，
然后因为年龄还比较小，
确实不知道怎么选择，
所以想跟你讲讲我的情况，
我是一毕业就考虑了体制内，
在县城工作，
工作两年之后遇到了一个对象，
他比我大三岁，
我是99年，
他96年的，
你俩都在姐姐妹都在一起上班，
然后家庭条件也非常合适，
各方面都很匹配，
都很快速的在一起谈恋爱了嘛，
但是恋爱十个月以来是经常吵架，
我前面两次他跟我提了分手，
后面他都挽回我了，
就是这一次分手，
他就是好像。
就彻底死心了那种，
知道自己还要不要继续。
我回忆复盘了一下自己恋爱的这10个月，
吵架的每一次的原因，
就大部分都是因为一些小事情，
就是没有原则性的错误，
但是因为我的优点就是他很会来受，
情商也很高，
然后工作能力很强，
对自己人生规划非常清晰，
是真心实意把我当做节对象你样去对待，
我在一起该过的节，
该送的礼物，
该陪伴我的地方，
他都做的特别好。
但是我们每次吵架的我就我能举出两个很经典的例子，
就是说他第一次给我过生日，
然后我就跟他说我都快过生日了，
然后他就说我家里人不过生日，
那说你想怎么过生日，
我说就给我买个礼物，
买吃个饭，
买个蛋糕，
他就答应了，
他是在晚上给我买了个香水，
礼物买了当天中午到了，
他就连着快递盒直接给我了，
就礼物都没有拆开，
也没有说等到生日那天，
大个惊喜，
你要给我，
这件事情我心里有点惦念你，
但我也没有说出来，
我还很感谢他，
但下午上班之后，
他发了之后我把任务完成，
你忘了吧，
他说就差蛋糕了，
他的蛋糕你自己挑一个吧，
他说我怕我挑了你不喜欢。
因为这句话我就生气了，
你说什么？
任务完成一半了，
礼物也干净，
没快递盒就提前交给我了，
蛋糕还让我自己挑，
然后我就很生气，
我也没有把电话打给他听，
我直接说你要不想给我。
我说那就算了，
我可以回去跟我父母过，
别也生气了，
他就开始跟我冷战，
不讲话，
但是他还正常接送我上下班，
我看到他正常接我下班了，
我觉得他始给我台阶了嘛，
然后我就很开心，
我就主动找话题跟他聊一先把这事儿给带过，
但是他就不搭理我，
一直跟我冷战，
我就有点崩溃，
我就说这么小的事情，
我说不能让他过去吗？
我说你不给我选蛋糕，
这样敷衍我的生日不是你的错嘛，
为什么还要这样冷暴力来惩罚我？
最后就吵架，
这是其一。
然后第二件事情就是每次我看见一件衣服很好看，
但那件衣服他很瘦，
我大概一米六八，
120斤左右，
我心里挺自卑自己，
我觉得自己挺差的嘛，
我看玩笑人家说我说这衣服好好看啊，
但是我穿不了，
然后他就说，
他说没关系，
你坐下来就可以穿了，
然后我就又生气了，
我说你就是嫌弃我看，
然后就是甩着脸子在那，
我不想换，
就希望他来哄我，
就是这是两件比较经典的事情吧，
谈恋爱10个月以来，
经常吵架，
也大多数都是为了这种类似的小事，
就是他一句话讲的不好呀，
或者是什么事就戳到我的，
我觉得他是瞧不起我，
嫌弃我，
批看我之类的，
然后这一次彻底分手是因为有一天下班回来，
然后咱们俩就坐沙发上，
鞋脱了我就闻跟他脚一眼臭，
我就不让你去穿个脚吧，
我这时候没什么兴趣，
他也没什么兴趣，
都很正常，
然后他就去卫生间冲脚，
然后我就。
着过去，
我说我也冲一个，
结果他就把脚伸到那个新的眼神子里面冲一，
我就觉得很离谱，
因为我有为一点点小节气了，
就说你怎么在新眼神里冲着来，
你来你一捏呀。
他听到这个话他也没有生气，
他就开玩笑说一句，
他说你鼻事还真多呢，
他我在这冲鸟怎么了，
他说我在这冲脚，
我心也不会湿，
我毛巾就拿过来了，
我知道他是在跟我开玩笑，
然后他平时确实也说话自比较直来直晚有人会说脏话，
我知道他不是针对我，
但是我知道他说你鼻这我给这一句话之后，
我就没感觉生气了，
我根本就听不清楚他后面解释的那些原因，
你就黑着个脸不说话，
他就喊我，
他这水热的快一些，
毛巾我都拿来了，
我说我就在这臭，
我说我着我以后再也不讲你了，
我就黑着脸就出去了，
坐沙发也不讲话，
看到我生气，
他就估计你也挺生气的，
他就也反着脸不讲话，
在那看底线，
那我看他不哄我，
他就要跟我冷战的样子，
我就更难受，
我，
我说明明是你说许多让我心里挺难过了，
你就不跟我道歉了，
他就说有什么道歉了呀，
又做错什么了？
他说你一个晚到了，
委屈什么呀，
这事情现在却闹成了这个样子，
他也彻底跟我不联系了，
那你现在想给姐帮你分析的事，
该不该去挽回，
做一下努力，
是想问我这个吗？
对，
离开你有差不多两周了吧。
这定义了很多事情啊，
我听了下来，
你们两个人都没有什么大的问题，
没有什么原则性的问题，
只是你们并不合适，
原因是什么？
我跟你就比如说过生日这个事情，
像有的人他很在意这个点，
他就寄希望于在过生日的时候被重视，
在过生日的时候能够给你准备一点小意外小惊喜，
这是属于很正常的心理需求。
但像有的人他不重视这个例子，
我就不重视生日，
我不喜欢别人给我搞什么很多朋友啊，
或者是很多聚餐啊，
很多那个仪式啊，
我很抗拒那样的仪式，
但是很庆幸的是我找到了一个也不在意过生日的人，
就我俩就过生日的话，
就完全跟过普通的日子一样过，
我俩都不在意仪式感，
我俩就凑一块儿了，
我想表达什么意思呢？
如果你本人是在意生活的小细节，
在意小浪漫，
在意小惊喜，
你就找一个，
他也很在意这些东西，
且他认为过生日给你一个小惊喜，
给你准备蛋糕，
给你准备一个生日的聚会，
是一件很快乐的事情，
你就找这样的人，
千万不要试图我找一个人，
我去改变他，
我去用，
我一次一次发脾气，
一次一次冷战，
一次一次去调教他，
不要太累了。
所以你如果问我说龙飞姐。
我要不要去挽回这段感情的话，
第一，
你挽回也挽回不了，
因为通常一个男生说要分手，
且两个星期都不联系了，
他就是真的已经忍够了，
你去挽回，
你也挽回不了。
反而会让自己丢面子嘛，
我们女孩子这一辈子啊，
想要过得快乐，
过得幸福，
第一个课题是分析自己的需求，
充分的去了解自己，
在了解自己的基础之上去找那个合适的人，
找那个对的人，
这个事情没有什么对错，
没有谁能帮你分析一下，
说这这件事情是我太作了吗？
我不这样认为，
我认为你的需求都是正常的，
作为一个女孩子，
希望男生在过生日的时候给你一个小惊喜啊，
给你买心仪的礼物，
给你买蛋糕，
带你些蛋糕，
给你说一点窝心的话呢，
给你制造一点小仪式感，
我认为这些需求是属于正常的需求。
就是我分析我自己的性格，
我觉得我确实性格问题挺多的，
大说是来吸引我的魅力就是很明显，
就是我觉得他做事很有分围，
抛开我俩老早吵架来说，
他对我真的挺好的，
就花钱从来不含糊，
就我爸妈也都特别好，
特别上心，
他在家里也挺有话语权，
以前谈过一个妈宝男嘛，
然后所以后来我就很注意这方面的问题，
我就觉得诶，
在家里说的上话挺好的。
后来去过他家几次，
我观察他跟他父母，
包括跟他亲戚之间说话就是挺冲的，
比如说啊，
我们那一次一起去拿一个做你的帐夫，
他妈妈看到他妈妈就问了，
他说你这拿了什么呀，
自己也跟他妈说，
他说要你管什么东西，
跟他不我这他可能是太玩笑，
但是我觉得如果是这样的说话方式知道我，
或者我用这样的式知道我父母，
我觉得我父母可能会受不了，
但是从另外一个角度来讲，
家里的事情，
大大小小的事情，
但父母的保险呀，
父母的一些体俭呀，
什么他都照顾的很到位，
就唯独是说话这一块，
确实有时候就是团结的嘛，
不好说吧，
姑娘，
这个男生本身呢，
他也是一个很优秀的男生，
但这个男生他真的不太适合你，
你如果跟这个男生再去复合的话，
还会重蹈覆辙，
因为你不可能改变他，
他也不可能为你而改变，
与其这样内耗的话，
不如。
承认就是承认，
人家也很优秀，
承认只是不适合，
仅此而已，
感觉自己你没有死心了，
却好是又遇到一个自己喜欢的时候，
他也喜欢我的，
然后过3年也特别合适，
也没有任何原则性问题，
他人这个样子就双方父母都见过，
他父母对我也特别好，
我爸妈也没喜欢他，
家庭就是闹成这个样子，
就感觉确实有一点点可惜，
嗯，
其实不可惜，
如果在一段感情里面，
你始终是那个怀疑自己内耗，
自己情绪不稳定的状态的话，
其实这不是郑源姑娘，
你刚看你那时间，
我就看了很多听你前的书，
然后也听了很多博客，
也跟很多身边的朋友聊了聊，
那个大大咧咧的女生，
他就跟我分析这个事情，
他就觉得就我自己脑子里的想法不对，
然后他就要别人来附和我，
所以我就在想啊，
有没有可能我去学习一下，
改变一下自己这种一种情绪，
就嗯，
黑着脸，
就需要别人跟我道歉啊，
就上头啊，
这种学着控制一下自己的情绪，
然后用这种撒娇的方式啊，
跟他讲，
哎，
你能不能下次不要这么凶慕，
我可以好好跟我这是可以的，
姐妹你去学一下那个撒娇宝典，
他的撒娇课，
这个是可以的，
我们在跟任何人沟通的时候，
我们用别人更容易接受的方式去表达我们的诉。
这是我们毕生需要学习的一个课题，
那我们将来是跟谁谈恋爱，
跟谁成为夫妻，
都要学会用别人更容易接受的这种方式，
嗯，
这用甩点子呀，
垮脸呀，
冷战呀这个方法，
不管是对谁都不好，
一定要学会表达需求，
也会直接的提要求，
学会让别人，
哎，
还很舒服，
你提了这个要求候，
他不光是愿意去满足你，
且在满足你这个要求的时候，
他自己很快乐，
很舒服，
一定要学这个技能，
这个是可以学会的，
反正你不断想学就行了，
觉得是我们今天沟通出了问题，
而且我觉得如果我真的能做到像我本来简单用这种撒娇的方式，
而不是黑着脸让别人跟我道歉，
我觉得他应该是乐意配合我的，
这个阶段你千万不要去低三下四的去求他，
你这个阶段应该是什么？
应该是到处拍照片，
就是把自己打扮的漂漂亮亮的，
然后如果你要是觉得自己有点嗯，
胖嘟嘟的啊，
你可以那剪一点就剪一剪，
就是不要去求他，
你可以发朋友圈，
什么时候他觉得哎呀，
他找不到更好的了，
他有可能会来找你。